you
No
Oh
you
please be seated good morning and
welcome to the 2011 commencement
exercises of the Columbia University
College of Dental Medicine our College
was founded in nineteen sixteen admitted
its first two pre doctoral students in
1917 and graduated those two students in
1922 so this is the 89th such springtime
graduation ceremony of the College of
metal medicine also also as you realize
we will soon be celebrating than
centennial anniversary of the founding
of our school in the years to come
whatever professional challenges you
face your Columbia education will be
there to define you and we know that we
have prepared you well to what lies
ahead dental school especially at
Columbia is rigorous and we feel that
perhaps the Columbia curriculum is the
most rigorous of any in the nation we
have laid the foundation but there is so
much more for you to learn we know that
you will continue to develop personally
and professionally taking your place
with our other alumni who are leaders in
patient care dental education and
research in the United States and across
the globe we must take a moment to
recognize those in the audience or
elsewhere who have supported our newest
alumni throughout the journey
financially emotionally with love and
understanding often a great personal
expense expense and sacrifice the
parents the grandparents siblings
spouses children relatives and friends
who have been so important in the lives
of our graduates let's please give them
a round of applause
I would also like to recognize our
dedicated faculty these individuals are
true innovators in dental education
patient care programs in research and
discovery the faculty that have guided
these young professionals through the
development of their cognitive and
clinical skills they are behind me on
the dais and in the audience and again
let's acknowledge their contributions
now our invocation dr. Janelle Davis is
the columbia university chaplain and
director of the earl hall center where
she oversees the office of university
chaplains community impact and the
United campus ministries dr. Davis also
holds the honorary title of chapter
chaplain to the College of Dental
Medicine it is my pleasure to introduce
dr. Davis to deliver the invocation for
those of you who made it downtown
yesterday thank you and I'm very
grateful that we weren't soaked
congratulations to each of you dentistry
is critical to the oral hygiene good
health and the quality of life of
children women and men you will be
trusted doctors seen as critical points
of entry into health care systems as
dentist oral surgeon and advanced
specialists you may be the first health
care professional to see debilitating
symptoms of poor nutrition and the early
evidence of chronic illnesses like
diabetes HIV or even cancer for the
diagnostic and preventive interventions
and care that you provide gratitude will
sometimes be unspoken but doctors know
that you will contribute to the health
well-being and dignity of your patients
you will be leaders in public health and
essential partners for justice and
health care may each of you have the
courage and the humility to be humane
partners in health care gentle
compassionate and patient healers may
you be blessed with wisdom good humor
and a peaceful spirit may it be so may
it be so amen
I would next like to introduce dr. Lee
Goldman he will bring greetings from the
Columbia University and from our Medical
Center dr. Goldman is the Herald and
Margaret hatch professor of medicine in
the College of Physicians and Surgeons
professor of Epidemiology in the mailman
School of Public Health executive vice
president for the health and biomedical
sciences and Dean of the faculties of
the health sciences and medicine dr.
Coleman what's a real privilege to be
here this morning to welcome the
graduates their families and friends as
dr. Lamster said here at the Health
Sciences we have four schools as you
know medicine dentistry nursing and
public health I have faculty
appointments in two of them but my
grandfather was actually a dentist the
students graduating today shared their
pre clerkship curriculums with the
medical students really symbolizing the
fact that he we here at Columbia think
of Health Sciences and the various
professions as being closely linked when
we go out into the world will each have
our own areas of specialization this
Chaplin Davis indicated sometimes
diseases are first seen by a nurse
sometimes first by a physician sometimes
first by a dentist for all of us to work
together is really critically important
during your training here you have seen
a medical center that has a remarkably
broad mission we care for people who
could go any place in the world and
sometimes do we also care for people who
have no other option but to get care
from us here locally and all of you have
worked in one way or another in settings
where you have helped provide that care
for the little local population here in
Washington Heights and Harlem a very
important part of our mission and the
mission we hope that you will continue
to embrace throughout your careers
during your careers as I have often been
quoted it will be important for you to
continue to learn this is not the final
step I've been quoted and I'll say again
that when I was in training in medical
school half of what i learned turned out
to be wrong and half of what i learned i
forgot every day i hope it's the same
half i know that much more than half of
what you've learned here will prove to
be right science medicine dentistry all
the health professions of advanced
substantially since the Dark Ages when I
was in training we also know this is not
the end of your learning it's really a
step along and it's lifelong process we
in the Health Sciences take great pride
in all of you it's wonderful to join you
here on your graduation and to see all
the happy faces and your parents and
friends very special day congratulations
to you all
our next speaker represents our Alumni
Association so I guess you're all alumni
now but was the president gave you your
degree or yesterday but you'll
officially be alumni in just about an
hour our alumni association is one of
the great strengths of the College of
Dental Medicine the president of the
Alumni Association is dr. Margot Jaffe
Margo earned her dental degree from
Columbia in 1980 her certificate in
pediatric pediatric dentistry from
Columbia in 1981 and then an orthodontic
certificate from Columbia in 1985 Margo
is a longtime advocate for our dental
school a great friend and an active and
effective president of the Association
of dental alumni yesterday I think you
all know with the pleasure of being with
her at the university graduation when
she was awarded awarded the
Distinguished Alumni metal one of only
11 columbia alumni to receive that award
yesterday and there are nearly 300,000
columbia alumni is a pleasure to
introduce Margo to deliver the message
good morning everybody it is my pleasure
today to speak to you on behalf of the
columbia university college of dental
medicines Alumni Association I want to
congratulate the entire class of 2011
and you're thrilled and supportive
families you represent the best and
brightest dental graduates in the United
States and your accomplishments should
fill you with pride and excitement
although your formal graduate education
is complete the majority of you are
pursuing postgraduate residences and
specialty training programs this is
consistent with a long-standing
tradition of our students seeking
additional knowledge and expertise in
addition to the rigorous didactic
current Killam that you have mastered
the faculty has imparted in you a firm
value system with ethical tenants that
will remain a core foundation to build
upon
our goal of creating competent confident
and compassionate young clinicians has
been realized we the alumni are your
advocates and your colleagues use us as
a resource the Association can serve as
a bridge between dental school and your
future professional endeavors we hope
that we have fostered a sense of loyalty
to the Columbia family and count on your
future participation stay in touch with
us attend our alumni events and see
e-courses mentor volunteer teach and
when you are able contribute to the
institution that prepared you well for a
promising professional career good luck
to all of you
and the wards are not over yet my
goodness this is heavy we're really very
pleased to be able to present Margot
with this award from the school to
acknowledge her contributions and let me
just read it simple message the
association of demo alumni of Columbia
University presents this plaque to
Margot Jaffe an appreciation of her
outstanding service and dedication as
president made 2008 to may 2011 the
normal term is two years we drafted
Margo for a third year so
congratulations
our next speaker is dr. Chad already
class president further for 2011 Chad
was actually his class president for all
four years chad is known for his
dedication to his class his level of
tolerance and focus on the CVM community
I met with him I think monthly we met
monthly to discuss the workings of our
pre-dental curriculum and I represented
the class of 2011 extremely well it is a
pleasure for me to introduce Chad to
offer his remarks on behalf of the class
team 2011 you guys look really good did
you ever think we'd be here thank you
for the last four years I feel honored
to be your colleague and I hope very
much that we all remain in contact
throughout the years to come a few weeks
ago I flew down to florida to look for
an apartment near the residency program
i will be starting this is a university
that I was extremely excited about and
while I was in the area I stopped by the
school to speak with some residents and
students I ended up in a conversation
with a fourth-year dental student there
weeks away from his own graduation when
he heard my plans to join his university
he sarcastically said good luck
surviving this place and then he let me
know how excited he was to leave I was
shocked he was talking about the people
the experiences and the institution that
made him exactly what he wanted to be a
dentist what more could they have done
to satisfy him perhaps he refused to be
satisfied and how could he have had
these hard feelings about the period of
his life that yielded his life's
greatest achievement surely I thought to
myself my classmates and I have never
felt this way but after honest
reflection I remembered that there were
hard times in dental school very hard
and during those times
all too easy to find fault and focus
only on what was lacking especially the
times when our clothes and hair wreaked
of cadavers when we were running on very
little sleep when we experienced a
particularly rough exam or when a
patient or two or three failed to show
up for a very important appointment we
have all been at the place at some point
in dental school when we focused or even
searched for what was missing oblivious
to the many good things around us but I
hope that as we look back on the years
we spent training training to become
dentists that we remember only the good
things an author wrote both abundance
and lack exists simultaneously in our
lives it is our conscious choice which
garden we will tend when we choose not
to focus on what is missing from our
lives but are grateful for the abundance
that is present love health family
friends work the joys of nature and
personal pursuits that bring us
happiness the waste land of illusion
falls away and we experience heaven on
earth this author represent references
the simultaneous existence of good
things and hard things in our lives and
there is no place this is more evident
than in dental school we enjoy
phenomenal professors we find true
friends in our classmates and we have
deadlines board exams troubling patients
even requirements we sometimes bite hard
to understand when we encounter
challenges and problems in our lives and
dental school has had many challenges it
is often difficult for us to focus on
what is good at life but even during the
most challenging times there have been
so many things to be grateful for and I
want to take this chance to remind
everyone here of one of life's truest
principles that choosing to be grateful
makes you happy for example often in
school I have felt like dentistry is
manual labor dentistry is hard on your
body
hands are tired your shoulders are tired
your back is tired and sometimes at the
end of a long day in clinic it's all we
can do to stumble home and fall into bed
but I know that each one of us is
grateful that our bodies are strong
enough to endure the rigors of dental
work likewise many of us feel the burden
of student loans but we live in a land a
free land where we can choose our
profession and where the resources do
exist that allow us to borrow the cost
of school and then have the luxury to
pay it back slowly over our careers what
a blessing this is instead of feeling
burdened by our student loans we can
choose to be grateful that a resource
exists that allows us to follow our
dreams we are grateful that Columbia's
admissions saw something special in each
of us that made them feel like we belong
to here we are grateful for the specific
way our class was constructed with the
diverse mix of personalities skills and
interests within this eclectic group
each of us has bound lifelong friends we
are grateful to attend a dental school
with a relatively small class the 74 of
us have spent all day every day together
for the last four years this experience
gives us a unique bond that we will
share for the rest of our lives our
class size has made us an intimate group
of colleagues and I hope that we will
remain as close as we are now over the
years we are grateful for the
opportunities that our time at Columbia
has afforded us not every dental school
has a Dean as committed to global health
as Dean Lamster our Dean's have
encouraged us to participate in
international charity missions excused
us from class to do so and even
organized a fund to subsidize the costs
of these trips more than three-quarters
of our class have traveled to the
Philippines Cambodia the Dominican
Republic Guatemala El Salvador and
Jamaica to treat patients who have no
access to dental care we found joy in
these opportunities to serve and we look
forward to future opportunities to share
the skills we've been given
we are grateful to our families who have
supported us ever since the day we told
them that we wanted to do something so
hard and so expensive and something that
would take so many years of our lives as
to go to dental school our parents
husbands wives and even children have
been patient with us and understanding
with us over the last four years we have
probably turned to you at some point on
the verge of complete meltdown and you
have led us cry on your shoulders and
you'd listen to us with an understanding
ear you let us rant and rave on the
telephone about how hard school is and
how unfair something or another seems
and you have supported us and reminded
us that there is life outside of
pharmacology immunology anatomy and
dentures thank you we wouldn't have made
it through without you we are grateful
for the faculty for sacrificing their
the freedom and financial rewards of
private practice in order to spend their
time here with us and share their
knowledge and passion for excellent
dentistry they have made our lives
better in many ways they believed in us
they believed in our ability to become
skilled caregivers even when we question
ourselves they spent hours of what
should have been their free time writing
letters of sincere recommendation in
hopes of opening future doors for us we
recognize their sacrifice and we will
always be grateful to them I hope that
our lives will be a reflection of this
gratitude as we give of ourselves to
those who follow in our footsteps we are
grateful for dr. you on who cared so
much about us that he spent his last
month's alive teaching us the parts of
human and human anatomy most crucial to
dentistry and begging us to know it
perfectly encouraging us to stretch to
the height of our full potential we are
grateful to good patients who
courageously open their mouths for
treatment even though they know we are
newcomers to this field we are grateful
to patients who trust us and we are
grateful for the patients who remain
seated dutifully in our chairs for hours
at times while we bustle about for
supplies
and look for professors we are grateful
for the chance we've had to live in
study and one of life's great one of the
greatest cities on earth and enjoy all
that New York has to offer we are
grateful to be part of a profession that
allows us to feel the joy of relieving
the pain of a patient and the
satisfaction of restoring a beautiful
smile we are grateful for the chance to
do dental work on each other in this
crowd you will see the excellent results
of Invisalign crowns veneers whitening
treatments and lots of tender loving
care we are grateful to one another as
classmates for teaching us for pep talks
for fun times for sharing the burden of
responsibility and especially for a
listening year when we needed someone
who really understood what a rough time
we were having we couldn't have done it
without each other and I know that
mutual love respect and support will
still be there in the years to come and
now the dental school is over we were
even grateful for the hard times because
they made us stronger because they made
us recognize how much we are capable of
and because the hard times are the times
that brought us together when we choose
to focus on the many many ways dental
school has blessed our lives we are
happy because when we feel gratitude
there is no place for arrogance concede
or animosity gratitude initiates love
and friendship when we are grateful we
want to serve others and share our
skills a Greek philosopher said he is a
wise man who does not grieve for the
things which he has not but rejoices for
those things which he has choosing to be
grateful will make us happy at times
stressful situations in dental school
and in life create overwhelming
circumstances where misunderstandings
between friends can occur if this has
happened to anyone please find something
about the relationship to be grateful
for focus on that and let the rest go we
are going to be to team 2011 for a very
long time and we need everyone choosing
to be grateful about the good in a
situation does resolve disputes
strengthen friendships and make us
better men and women team we have shared
so much over the last four years
we have everything to be grateful for
and so much to look forward to I know
that as we remember to be grateful for
the good things in our lives and to show
that gratitude by serving others that
our lives will leave bowling happy team
2011 I love you congratulations
Thank You Jen our commencement address
this morning will be delivered by dr.
william cannon but accounting practices
general dentistry in rochester new york
and is the president-elect of the
American Dental Association he's a past
president of the New York State Dental
Association and as a fellow in the
american college of dentists the
International College adventists and the
pfr shard Academy he is a native New
Yorker and graduated Magnus magna
laude from the state university of new
york college of environmental science
and forestry at Syracuse University and
received his dental degree from the
state university of new york at buffalo
it's really my pleasure to introduce dr.
Calvin
good morning Dean Lamster university
administration distinguished faculty
loyal staff proud family and guests it
is a great honor for me to be here this
morning to acknowledge the members of
the class of 2011 today the spotlight is
distinctly on you for your unbelievable
accomplishments my sincere
congratulations I've attended and spoken
at enough commencements to know that the
graduates like for the speeches to be
short and the families like for the
speeches to be even shorter so I'm going
to try to offer some insights into
professional world you're about to enter
give you a few words of advice and still
try to keep those smiles on all of your
faces I am speaking as a person who has
been to dental school three times once
for myself once for my older son and
daughter-in-law who graduated three
years ago and I am currently feeling
enrolled with my younger son who was
just entering his third year parents you
know what I mean we so often live our
lives through our children and because I
am on the 12 year plan I have had
countless countless dental students
sitting around my kitchen table I home
venting their concerns and expressing
their dreams I understand very well what
you have been through during your dental
education and we are here today to
celebrate your successful completion of
one of the most demanding chapters of
your life and that's exactly what it is
one chapter there have already been many
preceding chapters in your life
manuscript those in which you have
learned core values and form the
critical platform of your existence many
accomplishments have prepared you for
this current chapter and for those you
should be very proud so what about the
chapters that lie ahead
well in a few moments you will finally
be able to say I'm a dentist and use the
title doctor well this is Columbia not
Hogwarts and whereas you are leaving
with knowledge skills and respect you
will not receive any magical powers or
even a one today I wish someone had
clued me in on that at my graduation my
family took me out to a nice restaurant
that evening and we had a great time i
sat in a heavy wooden chair on the side
of the table next to a wall a wall of
solid mirrors I decided to some point to
get up and use the men's room and push
my chair back and heard a sound that
wasn't healthy the sound of breaking
glass a couple of waiters came running I
stood up and held up my hand as if to
tell them they had it all under control
and I remember so well say in a loud
voice it's okay I am a dentist
while the look in their faces burst my
bubble of control real quickly and I
quickly realize that this title gives
you no free passes so what does it give
you to answer that will take most of the
three hours deem Lamster has given me
this morning just kidding d actually the
fact that you are entering the
profession of dentistry gives you
unlimited potential but no free passes
what you make of that potential is up to
you and the way in which you manage your
involvement in the profession is the key
change is all around us and believe me
it is constant the dental profession is
changing rapidly a generation ago most
of you would be looking to enter private
practice soon after graduation but a
much larger percentage of this class
will spend your careers in academia
research group practices the military or
perhaps in public health venues along
the way you'll have to deal with changes
and licensing requirements changes in
state and federal laws and even though
it may seem hard to believe right now to
you soon enough you won't be the most
up-to-date on changes in science and
technology and you will have to adapt
the way you practice to keep up with a
state-of-the-art change can be scary but
it can also be extremely stimulating
during your career in fact possibly
early in that time dentistry will become
much more integrated into primary care
the role of oral care will become
recognized as more involved in total
healthcare the scope of practice of
dental professionals may well expand as
oral care is no longer marginalized in
the health care continuum be ready to
embrace changes as they present be a
pioneer shepherding appropriate change
is one of the charges of your new title
in the past many dentists were happy to
stay within the four walls of their
offices and isolate themselves in the
world
they were contempt doing good dentistry
in my estimation those days are long
over because the impact of so many so
many external forces on a profession has
escalated exponentially we no longer our
cottage industry we are now mainstream
and we must learn to swim against the
current if necessary that current is
strongest when we address the issues of
providing oral health services to the
thirty percent of our population who for
various reasons have difficulty
accessing or utilizing dental services
there are entities some with major
financial resources and some with
political influence that believe that
new models of delivery of care are the
only answers many propose that new
levels of practitioners all with much
less training that you have should be
able to perform many of the skills that
you have perfected over the last four
years I suggest to you that barriers to
care go far beyond workforce and include
situations such as geography language
culture and oral health literacy in the
long run concerns about access to care
will not be answered by increasing the
capacity of workforce but rather by
decreasing demand that will be
accomplished by education and prevention
being the linchpins of a very
comprehensive approach in recent years a
profession has embraced the need for
increased social responsibility I urge
you sincerely urge you to join in the
movement to have dentistry be a major
player in community dynamics the
complexity of our profession makes it
virtually impossible to make a
difference as an individual I mentioned
earlier your need to be involved in your
profession as you were told a few
minutes ago I am next year as president
of the American Dental Association
the ad a represents nearly seventy
percent of all the dentists in the
United States I feel obligated just for
a moment to share with you the first
goal of the ad a strategic plan and that
is to provide support to Dennis so they
may succeed and Excel throughout their
careers no matter what career path you
choose within the profession of
Dentistry the a DA is there for you you
need to be involved with a professional
association there are several specialty
associations ethnically based societies
study clubs just join so you can make a
difference position yourselves so that
rather than being part of a problem you
are major part of the solution but I
urge you always be part of the
mothership the ad a you here are
Columbia have a rich history of
involvement and asked of the American
student Dental Association in fact you
have had several national presidents one
of you is now the immediate past
president of Asda Thank You Cora Corman
for your leadership I was very proud to
be with you there it's several meetings
now for the few words of advice I
promised you in your professional life
you will encounter what I refer to as
unguarded moments those times in which
you're very basic values the very values
that make you who you are will be
challenged in professional lingo they
are known as ethical dilemmas because
but I call them unguarded because you
are on your own just you and your
conscience nobody else there to offer
you guidance it might be about advising
a patient about a broken root tip
following an extraction although we know
that never takes place or perhaps the
patient that asks you to do them a favor
and alternates claim to help them out
financially or maybe the reporting of
data following a scientific experiment
that doesn't support your research goal
or maybe the urge to suggest unnecessary
crowns toward the end of the month so
you can pay your bills
if for even even a fleeting moment you
have to think about it back away take a
very deep breath and ask yourself is
this the right thing to do never never
compromise your values believe me it is
not worth it I'm convinced that most
dentists fit a similar psychological
mold highly motivated a little obsessive
and very focused in the early stages of
my career my analogy of success was an
endless ladder that never let you reach
the top because you couldn't always do
better my wife is a psychologist and she
found that image to be very very
self-defeating she introduced me to a
totally different concept that didn't
exist in my concrete world but certainly
did to her in her more abstract way of
thinking to her life is a series of
islands all connected by little bridges
she suggested to me that as you proceed
through your career it's okay to do well
and stop it an island for a while and
rest and enjoy what you've accomplished
it's also okay to stay there or choose
to move on to the next Island in other
words it's okay to tell yourself that
you've done well and enjoy that success
that one conversation probably impacted
me more than any other in my life so far
your takeaway should be strike a balance
in your life your profession will be a
major part of your existence but don't
let it consume your life place family
religion and community where they
deserve to be and learn to prioritize
the various pieces of your life's puzzle
both of my kids were runners all through
school so how appropriate that we're
standing on a track here
there is a poster hanging in our house
with a picture of a man running up a
very steep hill the saying below that
picture is the highest reward for a
person's effort is not what they get for
it but rather what they become by it you
have all done well to be here today now
take what you have earned all of your
knowledge and skills invest those
earnings wisely and reap the benefits go
make a difference in the world again
congratulations
thank you Bill so we actually giving out
75 not 74 75 awards or acknowledgments
today and each year we present one
faculty award at graduation like the
lady Moss Valentine who is vice dean for
academic affairs will present were
presented the Edward visa garelli
Teaching Award dr. Moore something Dean
Goldman Dean Lamster dr. Kalman
colleagues new colleagues families and
friends I wants more ways to add my
congratulations to all of you on this
important day you have worked hard and
today you will hold that document that
tells you in the world that you have
succeeded and if I just move on you will
get it okay so i will make it as really
brief it is customary during this
ceremony to honor a member of the
faculty for excellence in teaching the
sega rally award is named after the late
dr. edward sega rally a former dean of
the College of Dental Medicine this
coveted award is given to a member of
the faculty who in the opinion of a
selection committee of faculty students
and alumni has distinguished him or
herself as a teacher the recipient of
this year's sega rally Award for
Excellence in teaching is dr. Rosanna
Graham Roseanne able to come
doctor grayham Arab earned her
bachelor's degree in 2001 at st. John's
University a dds degree in 2005 here at
Columbia and in that same year she also
earned an MA degree in science education
from Columbia University Teachers
College and she Debbie became our first
graduate in the DDS ma dual degree
program doctor grayham joined our
faculty five years ago after a year of
postdoctoral GPR training she has taken
full advantage of her education at
Teachers College she has introduced
several innovations in a program and she
is known and appreciated as a caring and
conscientious teacher I should also
mention that in between she completed a
PhD degree in science education last
year it is with the greatest pleasure
that I present this important award to
dr. Rosen agree
let me add my thanks and my
congratulations rosana really represents
us all of us as the best that Colombia
can produce now the presentation of
diplomas note that yesterday we had our
annual class day when individual awards
were presented these awards are noted in
the program and we again congratulate
those students who are so honored
joining me to present the diplomas will
be vice dean Moss Alan tyne vice dean
Ron Meyers associate dean martin davis
senior associate dean martin davis and
dr. richard lagoon fall whose chair of
the section of adult industry I asked
them please to come forward
good morning to all we have spent a lot
of time together this is a culminating
moment when you were selected to be in
this class there were 30 other
candidates for each of you who wanted to
be in your positions you have worked
long you have worked hard you have
suffered and you have had joy this is a
perfect moment to celebrate all of those
emotions over ninety percent of you will
go on to postdoctoral education that is
more than any other dental school in the
country we will now present your
diplomas parents and friends you are
welcome to come forward and take
photographs please do so though just
when your candidate is here so that we
can keep the aisle open this is being
videotaped we need to keep the sight
lines clear we will also have a
professional photographer take
photograph of your important graduate
with the Dean during the presentation of
the actual diploma you'll be contacted
later if you'd like a copy of one of
those photographs we will observe
several traditions here this morning
beginning with the placement of the hood
on each member of the class by vice dean
myers several class members have family
who are health care professionals we
will ask them to come forward and assist
with the placement of the hood if you
are one of them when you are called to
place the hood on the doctor please come
forward at that time after you've placed
the hood please return to your seat by
the same route you came up here the Dean
will present the diploma and stand with
each graduate for the official
photograph vice dean mas 17 will
continue our tradition of presenting
each graduate with a special gold lapel
pin this tradition was begun by a
donation from one of our alumni dr.
Christopher Bonacci the class of 92 with
us md 95 in the belief that a
significant momentum of this moment is
important
and in the hopes that the graduates will
wear the pin proudly at future alumni
events together doctors each row should
move to that side come up one at a time
and across the stage in this direction
are you ready we now present the
diplomas dr. Marvin abarca
dr. Michael Abrams
dr. vishal Advani
dr. Chad already dr. Allred's mother
will hood him mrs. Dori Schiraldi who is
an RN
dr. Nicholas andris
dr. Etta Bernstein
dr. Kavita Balala dr. malala's sister
dr. Vindi Patel who is a dentist will
help with her hooding
dr. andrew boyd dr. Boyd's father who
was a dentist will assist him with the
hooding we hope thanks to
dr. a milk Cappetta
dr. Michelle karoon tio dr. Karen chios
father died cope dr. Michael Corinne CEO
who has a dentist will assist with the
hooding
dr. ki shaan dr. Chan's at dr. Maria
Marin a dentist will assist with the
hooding
dr. Mary Beth cheatham
dr. J away Chang
dr. Jung in joy dr. Choi's father Dr Yun
Chao joy a dentist will assist in the
hooding
dr. Mona danesha dr. Dennis fiance dr.
Simon Balin of the class of 10 of the
College of Dental Medicine will assist
in her hoodie
dr. hi doh oh right
dr. stephanie dominion dr demain ian has
asked her mentor dr. Lipton fall to hood
her
dr. Amanda idelson dr. Idol sins father
dr. Richard idelson a dentist will
assist in her hooding
dr. Andrew Fisher
dr. Jeffrey Fung
dr. eric frank dr. Frank's father dr.
Lawrence Frank a physician will assist
with his hooding
doctor I not galore dr. galarza
father-in-law dr. Barry Cohen a
physician will assist with her hoodie
dr. Adam biga true doctor get shoes
father dr. Paul getriebe class of 82
College of Dental Medicine will assist
with the hooding
dr. Peter Greco
dr. chuckling hey Kerr
dr. June harewood June has also attained
a met and MA in science education from
teachers college simultaneously
dr. Corwin d hockey dr hopf key is also
a new father
Christopher Shaw
Michael flung
amalia a kitchen
go bar you're a bunny
dr. mark giardino
dr. radhika kapoor
dr. Violetta Vayner paintings Berg dr.
Kane expert will be hooded by her
husband dr. Eugene Kennex Burke CDM plus
of 07
dr. Renata kelem ski dr. kalam ski will
be hooded by her father dr. Maxim
kolinsky a dentist
dr. Yoo Kyung Kim
dr. ki jung kim
dr. Sean Kim
dr. gloria lee dr. Lee will be hooded by
her sister dr. grace lee who just
received her dental degree from the
University of Michigan
dr. Amy Lebovitz
dr. Eva Leroy dr. Leroy will be hooded
by her mother dr. Marika whole Jeff a
dentist
that's it
dr. some nhung limb
dr. annika lindgren dr. lindgren will be
hooded by her sister dr. christina
lindgren deposition
dr. petrol magician
dr. Sandra whose oma Bibby
dr. lauren and mid tun dr mattoon who
will have her hood placed by dr. Richard
Mattoon her father and a physician
dr. Steven nadler
dr. Eric niermann dr. niermann will be
hooded by his father-in-law dr. David
Rahman a physician
dr. Ludmila Norma tova
dr. Gorrie Parulekar
dr. Christine park
dr. Jake sangchul hark
dr. huge own Jennifer Hart
dr. Schimmel patel
dr. David Perino dr. ferrino will be
hooded by his father dr. Michael Perino
College of Dental Medicine 1976 dr.
Samuel Hollen
dr. Renee Reynolds
dr. Stacy Robinson
dr. marina Rodriguez dr. Rodriguez will
be hooded by her sister-in-law dr.
Jeanne Olive CDM class of twenty
thousand ten
dr. nimah rouhani
dr. Edward Rudolph
dr. faria samad
dr. rupali Shaw
dr. Ellen oz should story Moghadam
dr. Yvonne we when sue
dr. LaVon Sookie ASEAN
dr. psych it sing
dr. yumna valeu la
dr. Kelley Fleming walk
dr. leora Walter dr. Walter will be
hooded by her father dr. Leslie Walter a
physician
dr. ND one
dr. Kyle Wicca sir
dr. Jennifer Wilbur
thank you all for being with us for the
ceremony and for your support of the
class of 2011 please join us for a
reception immediately following in the
Hall of Fame area in the lobby level
please remain in your seats little
housekeeping until the processional has
left the immediate air mediate area
first the faculty and then our newest
alumni and my last parting words be well
do good work and remain part of the
College of Dental Medicine thank you and
good afternoon
you